hunter biden's about to release a new
memoir he opens up about his drug
addiction and says he would not
repeat working for the ukrainian gas
company barisma um trey i want to bring
you in here as a former prosecutor
because the one thing i have not heard
from hunter biden or the biden
administration to say
is that the emails that came forward the
ones that tony bobilinski talked about
with tucker are mike emanuel
talked to other people who were on those
email threads who independently verified
them
i haven't heard him say the emails
aren't legit
yes shannon i think the reason you
haven't heard that is because no one's
asking i mean if you can't nail down
whether that computer is yours or
vladimir putin's
you're not making a ton of progress and
i mean
that is not a tough question did you are
you missing a computer
that might have been a great follow-up
question did you drop on offer repair
that might have been a decent follow-up
question
you know shannon he lost he lost his
mother
a sister and a brother and he's a
recovering addict and all of that is
tragic but when you write a book
and when you traffic in your father's
name you're going to be scrutinized and
all i'm asking is that the media and
social media
scrutinize him the same way they did the
trump children
and the bush children just be fair about
it don't let somebody get away with
saying you know what it's a jump ball it
could have been
putin's it could have been mine
katie do you think he's going to have
any of those tough interviews will there
be follow-up questions i mean you put
out a book and it's kind of one of those
times that you make the rounds and you
show up for everything including the
opening of an envelope
i don't know how much press he's going
to do or who he's going to do it with if
those are going to be some of the
questions
we'll see how many interviews hunter
biden continues to do
if he's going to respond in ways like
that you know he made a lot of money
in ukraine when it's like i don't know
where my laptop is
it may have gotten stolen i don't know
maybe i dropped it off i can't find it i
mean if i lost my laptop i'd be
looking for it right i mean most normal
people would but the bottom line is we
knew
this was his laptop in october mike
emanuel had you know got
his hands on the sheet where he hunter
biden signed it and dropped it off
at the computer repair shop there's a
witness who said that hunter biden
dropped it off
at the repair shop and then the campaign
never denied that it was his laptop so
this is a story that we knew about
it was buried by the big tech companies
twitter banned anybody who
dared to share it they banned the the
new york post for weeks on end for
publishing
legitimate stories with emails and text
messages to back up their claims
and yet here we are now with him saying
oh yeah it may have been my laptop and
then using
a talking point from the left in the
media that it was a russian
disinformation campaign so
the choices are may have been my laptop
or maybe it was stolen by the russians
and then used against me somehow
the bottom line is the evidence shows
this was hunter biden's laptop
so juan you know we all remember as
katie has outlined and as we've talked
about that the story when it came out
initially was
kind of tossed aside as russian
disinformation twitter locked down the
new york post who did the reporting on
this
now npr which had a book review out of
the new book yesterday had to issue a
correction
they had said that u.s intel discredited
the laptop story
they've now had to since come back and
say well actually that's not true
i mean juan what does the mainstream
media do with this story because
it's uncomfortable for them the role
they played you know in the in the
days leading up to the election
i think the correction shannon simply
indicated that
it's not us intelligence but there's no
credible evidence as to the
origins origins of that laptop and so
they don't know that's all they're
saying
i will say this i think that it's easy
to go after hunter biden the guy
it looks pretty weak i thought that
answer was totally limp you know i mean
there's nothing to it either he says he
owns it or he doesn't
i it's hard for me to believe he doesn't
remember but that's what he says and as
trey points out he's got a
troubled past especially with drugs and
the like and guns and
women everybody knows he's he's had a
boatload of trouble
but look you know i see this as going
after joe biden i saw a poll this week
said joe biden's at 60 percent approval
among voters
and yet i hear his critics saying oh you
know his wife puts
calls herself dr jill where the wife
earned a doctorate or people say
kamala harris she laughs too much she's
snickers and i think
yeah so what okay it looks to me like
your people are just looking they're
digging for something on this guy
we're we're talking about a book though
that hunter is out there selling he
wants you to buy it greg are you going
to buy it
right um i don't have to buy it i'll
probably just get it sent to me and
after i personally invite uh hunter to
be on my new show
gutfeld which i'm offering i'm inviting
him right now
and i will give him the floor here's the
thing
okay i if you're a junkie i understand
that everything could have happened
because you live in a world of lies
right
so it's it the only the best way to
remember stuff is the stuff
you said that was honest because you did
that once or twice
but here's the problem his memory is
good enough to write a massive memoir
so if he can remember a hundred hundreds
and hundreds of pages of his life
he probably remembers this laptop
because he gets into
pretty uh graphic detail from what i
understand about how his life unfolded
with the drugs and the sex and all the
other
fun stuff and uh and uh so i don't know
and
but the big question is that election
our election was compromised because
that
story was just was was in
made invisible through the collusion of
social network titans
and the press if people had known how
compromised the biden family was that
would have had an impact
somewhat maybe who knows marginally i
don't know on the election
and we'll never know i'm gonna put greg
down as a skeptic
on the book although when you get it let
us know how it is coming up highlight
the good parts
okay just give us the good stuff